Even good Hollywood movies can be hard to
watch twice.
In the case of these films, it's not bad writing
or uninspired performances that make the movies
hard to screen a second time.
Rather, they're so depressing, shocking, or
even terrifying that one cinematic exposure
to them is more than enough to last a lifetime.
In the case of these films, they're worth
watching — but you probably won't want to
see them again after that.
Requiem For a Dream
This adaptation of Hubert Selby's novel is
a brutal, bleak, and visceral film in which
Darren Aronofsky opens a window on the lives
and experiences of four different drug addicts.
And that view is decidedly grim.
"I like thinking about the red dress and the
television, and…"
The stunning visuals and harrowing story grab
hold of you and don't let go for 101 excruciating
minutes.
It's a mind-bender of a film that will leave
you depressed for days and seriously contemplating
your own bad habits.
Dogville
Lars Von Trier's movies all tend to fit in
the category of just-one-timers, and that's
certainly the case with the second installment
of his Land of Opportunity trilogy, Dogville.
This film, which is told in nine parts, chronicles
the grueling experience of a woman who, on
the run from the mafia, decides to hide out
in a rural town.
The residents agree to provide her shelter
in exchange for her completing their various
low-level chores.
But her relationship with the town descends
into unethical abuses of the woman, including
multiple sexual assaults — all very difficult
to stomach the first time around, let alone
on a repeat viewing.
Passion of the Christ
Director Mel Gibson threw everything he had
into this harrowing, vicious film about the
final days of Jesus Christ.
As the title indicates, it was meant to be
a showcase of just how much grace and conviction
the religious figure showed in the face of
extreme brutality from his executioners.
And while the film certainly did its job of
reminding its intended audience of the sacrifices
Jesus endured, even viewers who might've revered
its message the first time may have a hard
time bearing witness to the shocking level
of violence again.
Bad Lieutenant
Onscreen sexual violence can be upsetting
in virtually any form, but the sheer lechery
of the central character in Bad Lieutenant
is especially difficult to observe.
The movie serves to ultimately exonerate the
drug-addled, unpredictable officer.
But the journey to get to that point teems
with tough material that includes the assault
of a nun and his use of authority to force
two young women into a sexual act.
It's impossible to unsee the events of the
movie — and hard to imagine voluntarily
watching them again.
Boys Don't Cry
Hilary Swank's Academy Award-worthy performance
as Brandon Teena, a real-life transgender
man who was raped and murdered in 1993, was
certainly groundbreaking, as it shed light
on an underexplored sector of hate crimes
that were — and are still — being committed
against transgender individuals.
At the same time, it was also incredibly difficult
to bear and probably counts for many as a
movie that's worth watching once … but maybe
just the one time.
Irreversible
This 2002 French horror film tops many best
and worst lists precisely because of how horrific
its lengthy and gratuitous rape scene is.
The film tells the reverse chronological story
of a woman who is raped and beaten into a
coma by a notorious criminal.
And it includes several scenes of intense
cruelty and graphic violence that makes it
almost unwatchable the first time around for
any audience members with functional eyes.
We Need to Talk About Kevin
As prevalent as mass murder attacks might
be in real life, it's still quite hard to
enjoy any piece of artwork that tries to synthesize
the psyche and history of a young person who
commits these heinous acts.
In the case of We Need to Talk About Kevin,
an all-star cast delivers sound, impactful
work to peel back the layers of life that
led up to the title character's horrific actions.
"You did not."
That said, the movie is still difficult to
process and might leave viewers feeling unfulfilled
and even more hopeless and confused than before.
Maybe that's the whole point — to highlight
the sheer senselessness of it all — but
it's still hard to imagine working up an appetite
to watch it again.
Precious
Based on the autobiographical novel Push by
Sapphire, Precious made for incredible, indelible
cinema thanks to some blistering truth about
a segment of society most people might not
understand.
The movie tells the story of a young girl
whose life consists of parental abuse and
neglect first, poverty second, and whose struggle
to survive the mean streets and her even meaner
home life is a daily battle.
Anyone who's seen it no doubt walked away
a little different than they came in … if
unwilling to watch it again.
"You ain't gonna see me no more."
Blue Valentine
Derek Cianfrance's Blue Valentine brims with
raw emotion and sexuality, but it's the depressing
nature of the narrative that really resorts
this one to the dustiest shelves.
The film is a categorical showcase of rich
acting by its leads, Michelle Williams and
Ryan Gosling.
But the biting, bitter truth that even the
most earnest romances can sputter out so spectacularly
might hit a little too close to home, in a
very literal sense, for many viewers to push
play again.
Schindler's List
There's no doubt Schindler's List is one of
the most important films to ever grace a theater.
Steven Spielberg's adaptation of this work
of historical fiction gave light to the real
work Oskar Schindler did to save the lives
of his Jewish employees during World War II.
It painfully depicted the real horrors of
the era in unforgiving detail.
In fact, it's precisely because of the raw
sense of dread and devastation that it ranks
among those that must be seen at least once
— but is probably difficult to revisit for
most.
American History X
Tony Kaye's American History X went to some
incredibly disturbing lengths to capture the
true depravity that neo-Naziism inspires and
is fueled by.
And while the overarching narrative is optimistic
in the sense that empathy is within reach
for even the most seemingly unsalvageable
individuals, the road to that character recovery
is immensely upsetting to watch.
Not only are the language and imagery purposefully
offensive, but the acts of violence committed
in the movie are unspeakable.
It's hard to imagine anyone choosing to endure
it all again after seeing it the first time.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!